[Musique]
dans le centre ville de montréal
ce ne sont pas les locaux commerciaux
vacants qui manquent ni les bonnes idées
le projet crée des ponts par art
souterrain au fois-ci locaux vacants
durant trois mois à des artistes
émergents
un projet comme celui là en effet à d'un
côté va aider le milieu immobilier parce
qu'on montre leurs commerces vacants
sous les meilleurs auspices et de
l'autre côté ces jeunes artistes là pour
eux c'est c'est une scéne hoban de
pouvoir avoir un lieu de création et de
vendre sans intermédiaire leurs oeuvres
d'art a dû à des nouveaux
collectionneurs
l'initiative est financée par les
propriétaires fonciers et la ville de
montréal permet aux artistes de voir
plus grand
non j'ai besoin d'assez d'espacé font
juste pour laisser la pièce respirer
puis fit pu m'aider à la visualiser donc
c'est vraiment super un espace
accessible comme seul l'idée derrière le
projet est aussi de sortir l'art des
musées et des galeries et d'aller à la
rencontre des gens on sort du musée on
sort des fondations on vous rend partout
ailleurs ça permet aussi de faire
rencontres entre artistes et public un
peu plus chez les novices le public pour
en effet visité ces résidences
d'artistes et échanger avec eux c'est
vraiment une motivation qui le contact
avec le public c'est vraiment
intéressant si monsieur on a
on a un point d'entrée avec eux pour
voir communiqué et ça c'est vraiment
essentiel
on sent pas tout seul j'ai besoin de
vraiment de prendre des avis des gens de
voir comment réagit les artistes sont
jumelés par équipe de deux par locales
ce qui permettra de créer des ponts
entre les artistes aussi photographe et
on trouve une conversation assez
intéressant entraînons matière
différents une bouffée d'air frais après
une année de pandémie que limiter les
occasions diffusion et des changes pour
les artistes
artiste produit on n'est qu'à la maison
tavel tas et puis devant le comité de
sortir de montrer ces choses là ça fait
du bien
les organisateurs espèrent que
l'expérience créer des ponts inspirera
d'autres organismes
ailleurs au pays absolument en fait ce
projet là doit servir d'exemple et si on
peut faire en sorte que ça puisse
encourager d'autres organisations à
suivre le pas mais aussi mais marc ce
terrain et c'est de développer davantage
d'alliances je pense que ça peut servir
toute la communauté des arts
créer des pans est à découvrir jusqu'au
15 octobre ici n'est dit alexandre
chartier radio canada montréal